[Music]  on Halloween in 1978 we saw a deranged  serial killer Michael Myers another  three innocent teenagers the thing that  interests us another story is after 40  years could it be the monster has  created another so you don't believe in  the boogeyman no you should  my grandmother turns it to in that case  the time here I mean is Laurie Strode  it was almost a murder every day she  lives in fear he's coming back  Michael I have something you might like  to see you remember Laurie Strode  [Applause]  this for a long time  it is not safe for you to be on the  street tonight he was standing right  there in the doorway I prayed every  night that he would escape the hell did  you do that for so I can kill him he's  waited for this night  I've waited for him  is here I'm gonna go protect my family  happy Halloween Michael  you  [Music]  you